hey guys pete here today i've got a
recap of the expanse season four
we go through one of the ring gates
leaving our solar system
the soul system behind on a mission to
illus or new terra depending on who
you're talking to
and with james holden acting as an
emissary for the u.n
the rosie and its crew are uniquely
suited for this job because of their
experience with the proto-molecule
after the eros incident humanity has a
healthy fear
of the blue goo and this new planet has
large ruins that appear to have been
built by the proto-molecule or at the
very least
the beings that created it before we
dive in this is your spoiler warning
this video will discuss
everything that happens in the expanse
through season 4.
if you're not caught up then this video
won't be for you additionally i've read
all the available books and novellas
from the expanse series
but i won't include any future book
spoilers in this video
with that out of the way let's get to it
i don't want to spend too much time
focused on how we got to where we're at
in this video but i do think this quote
from the end of the season three finale
sets things up for the fourth season
perfectly
after the events that happened in the
slow zone are wrapped up we see a
montage of what all the different
characters are doing
as the ships are transiting back through
the ring into the soul system
in that we see a vision of holden
standing on a beach where he
says you've given us a new frontier
thirteen hundred
habitable systems on the other side of
those rings
you know we're going to go we won't be
able to resist
it's gonna be another blood-soaked gold
rush he continues
when you connected me to the station i
saw something the civilization that
built the rings is gone
wiped out what could have killed them to
that miller responds
that's what i'd like to know gonna need
a ride so the first part of that is a
description of where we're at and the
beginning of season four
rings that lead to 300 new habitable
planets
this is game changing and we see how all
the different factions are looking at it
early in season four
the barbapakola a ship full of refugees
from ganymede passes through a ring gate
and they run
a blockade at the un we see that
avasarala doesn't really want this to
happen she doesn't want everyone to just
rush through the rings and she's getting
some
pressure from other members of the
council the belters see an
opportunity to get a seat at the table
by repurposing
the behemoth into medina station so that
they can help
control the entry point to the rings so
that faction of the opa
has entered into an agreement with the
inners and together they
are enforcing the blockade holden makes
it back to earth he visits his family
and while he's there he sees what we'll
call proto miller who
encourages him to go through the ring
later he'll meet with avasarala she
tells them about the barbapicola
and that fact that they're on this new
planet mining lithium
she gives them the mission to go find
out what's going on with the planet
because of these
large ruins that look like they were
built by the proto-molecule
he accepts he fills in the crew and we
learn that naomi says that she's going
to the surface when they arrive
this is a big deal because she's a
belter and she's going to have to
prepare to be able to go down the well
so as the rossi makes its way back to
the ring gates she works on that
we see an exchange with amos talking to
clarissa mal
we learned that she's serving a life
sentence back on earth and that the two
of them formed a friendship on the way
back from the slow zone
we also see alex contact bobby who's on
mars staying with her brother
and having a hard time readjusting to a
civilian life
through a series of animation screens we
see that proto miller
is investigating the remnants of the
proto-molecule he says he's reaching out
reaching out so we have the conclusion
of miller's story going on in the
background in the foreground we have a
conflict between the refugees who made
it to illis first and a corporation
called royal charter
energy in desperation the refugees ran
the blockade so they're technically not
supposed to be there
their point of view is that they made it
there they discovered the lithium they
started to mine it and now this is their
new home
the rce has a charter issued by the u.n
but in reality they only got that
because the belters made it to the
surface
first they look at the belters as
squatters and it's this kind of
situation where nobody's really
100 right that's a big part of the
reason that abbasaralis sent the ross
ante there
there's a lot riding on what happens on
this planet and as we see as things
develop there's a million things that
could go wrong here
the leader of the rce group is adolphus
mercury who is
a very abrasive character and because he
has this charter he would never look at
what they're doing
as being legitimate under any
circumstances things go wrong
immediately when the rce
shuttle crashes on its approach this was
due in part to bad
timing the builders had a plan to buy
themselves some time by destroying this
landing pad
basically they knew this corporate
interest was going to be moving in
and they wanted to slow them down while
they were putting that plan
into action the shuttle arrived and
rather than aborting the mission they
went through with it
killing a lot of innocent people in the
process and we're introduced to a lot of
characters
inside of this conflict but i don't want
to spend a lot of time on their
backgrounds or who they are because a
lot of them
are sort of one season arcs it is worth
mentioning here though that not everyone
that's with mercury
is in lockstep with his ideas he has a
work group of scientists that are along
for the ride
that are there to study the new planet
the most important of those is elvi
akoye who
is an exobiologist she ends up working
with both sides the belters
and rce and also the rossi and its crew
when they arrive we see naomi on the
surface for the first time
breathing free air seeing a horizon she
ends up struggling to adapt and it
emphasizes part of the problem that the
ring gates present to belters as a whole
as we see with the refugees some of them
are able to adapt but even someone like
naomi who seems like a fine physical
specimen
and we saw that she worked hard in order
to get ready
still can't easily transition to being
on the planet
while the crew of the rossi is there to
kind of make sure things don't get out
of hand
they also unwittingly brought active
proto-molecule with them
on the ship later we'll learn that
that's why holden sees proto miller
and it's all part of his directive you
know back on earth he said he wanted him
to go through the ring this is all part
of the proto-molecule doing what the
proto-molecule does
so he gets holding to go to the ruins
and remove this root that's blocking a
connection there
when he does that it's like the
structure turns on in fact the whole
planet kind of turns on
we see lightning strikes start to happen
that are coordinated but unexplained
beyond the fact that it is related to
whatever holden turned on
things continue to escalate and
eventually holden fires a torpedo at one
of the structures
while holden is focused on the
proto-molecule amos actually works with
mercury briefly
they investigate the landing pad and
find evidence that someone blew it up on
purpose
that leads to open hostility from
mercury towards the belters
intention continues to rise between them
amos hooks up with chandra one of
mercury's crew
and they have a one season romance that
ends in tragedy
he winds up at odds with mercury as he
learns more about him
at one point he tells them he knows he's
a killer that he enjoyed killing one of
the belters right in front of everyone
he warns him from one killer to another
not to mess with him or the rest of the
crew
they make great adversaries and the
relationship with chandra gives us some
insight into how amos
thinks eventually mercury's group takes
amos into custody
and they go after lucia with naomi
stepping up to try to protect her they
chase them but they're able to escape to
the rosannante
and they go back up into orbit with alex
after alex and holden are able to help
them get on the ship
we do learn that lucia was responsible
for blowing up the landing pad but that
she tried to stop the plan when she
realized the shuttle was coming in for a
landing her co-conspirators weren't
worried about casualties
and wouldn't let her stop the plan from
going through naomi's involvement
ratchets things up for holden
and he punches mercury in the face at
one point he goes to get amos out of
custody
intending to evacuate the planet the
belters don't want to leave though
and so skirmishes continue to break out
and things get crazier
before any of this can be sorted out one
of the islands on the planet explodes
and then all the reactors stop
working the planet is essentially
fighting back
fusion drives don't work the shock wave
and the tsunami from
the explosion of the island will
eventually force
everyone on the surface to go inside the
ruins to hide from the fallout and while
they're there they start having problems
with their
vision and they also come across these
death slugs that will kill people
if they come in contact with them as
things are moving along mercury reveals
his motivations
they're to get a real payday from the
corporation because the lithium is worth
a lot
but the protomolecule tech is worth much
more
in order to pull all this off he plans
on killing holden so that he won't get
in his way
so on the planet everything's going
wrong the environment
itself is causing problems something's
going on with the proto-molecule tech
miller hasn't shown up to talk to holden
to explain what's going on there
and mercury is essentially going psycho
while that's all going on there's stuff
going on on earth on mars and in the
belt as well
just like on illus or if you prefer new
terra
we're introduced to a lot of new
characters in these different locations
but i'll try to do a rough overview of
just the important stuff
as mentioned bobby's on mars and she's
having trouble getting used to civilian
life
staying with her family she's working a
job her nephew gets himself into some
trouble he's doing some illegal activity
for a local gang
she finds out about it and beats some of
them up and destroys one of their labs
and then they kidnap him forcing her to
negotiate and she ends up having to
unlock a door at her job so that they
can go in
and take something she tries to go
report the gang at the police station
and the person who comes to interview
her
is the gang leader his name is acai and
he is a cop
so she gets caught up she tries to tell
her boss that backfires because he wants
to continue doing stuff and she doesn't
want to do it so he gets her
fired and in trouble again that puts her
directly under the thumb
of the gang and she goes along with them
and works for them for a period of time
they have a big job coming up and she
doesn't feel right about it so she goes
to visit acai at his house and we see
he's a pretty normal guy
and he discounts everything that she's
worried about because the payoff is big
enough that he can get his family off
the planet
and this is important in that he
explains to her what's really going on
with mars
with the ring gates opening the whole
terraforming project and everything else
that mars has been working on for all
this time
suddenly doesn't make sense anymore why
continue with the generations long
terraforming project
when there's access to 300 new habitable
systems out there it just doesn't make
sense anymore and therefore mars is
going to lose its power
people are going to leave and this is
part of why abasarala
is trying to stop the rush through the
rings
we see her do that back on earth and in
the process
she gets caught up in an election most
of that serves just to flesh out the
character of who abba sarala
is we see that she is a skilled
politician and she's willing to do
things that make
everybody else around her uncomfortable
the campaign against nancy gal
highlights her strengths and weaknesses
and serves to show how different
factions of the opa
are able to make things difficult for
the un in their attempt to hold things
back
from going crazy out of the rings in the
belt we see a number of different things
play out
i mentioned that the main faction of the
opa entered into a truce with the inner
planets
they established medina station to
control the ring space
so that they have leverage and a say in
what happens as
people start to move through the rings
not all of the builders are on board
though and we get this perspective
when we meet marco anaros we know that
he was involved with naomi and they had
a child named phillip we knew that she
had some background but we didn't really
know exactly what happened
and we hear her tell her side of the
story to lucia when they're in orbit and
we learn what really happened between
them
essentially marco tricked her into
writing code telling her they were going
to disable
ships and then they could go back and
rescue them to get paid
later instead he used that code to
overload the reactor on a ship in the
docks at luna
and that killed 516 people she was
devastated when she found out she was
responsible for all those deaths and he
tried to use that
and her son against her in order to keep
her on his side
so she ended up leaving because she
couldn't see another way out of the
situation
ashford and drummer get marco in custody
and he lays out his intentions vaguely
to ashford
basically he sees the inner planet
screwing over the belt again with this
expansion
and brings up the real problem that many
of the people who are belters can't live
on those planets
anyways and their livelihoods are going
to be affected
as civilization moves out to these outer
planets
and isn't as reliant on the resources
from the belt anymore
he thinks the belt has a real chance to
increase their power
and when ashford says they don't have
nearly enough in the way of weapons or
ships
marco hints that there is something
going on with mars
an arrangement or something but he
doesn't lay out all the details
either way the opa is about to space him
for breaking the truce
they bring in the other factions and
they decide to let him
speak his mind and explain the situation
before they decide whether they're going
to kill him
he delivers a compelling monologue he
explains his position
and offers to forfeit the money he made
from taking the colony ship
the different factions are split on
whether to let him live drummer
actually breaks the tie which shocks
ashford but believes it's the best thing
to do since the other factions were
sympathetic and she knows they'll turn
on him
if they kill him after they let him go
he causes problems for
everyone with a ship called the pazuza
where he rigged it to blow up basically
but leaked information to the un that he
was going to be on it so they had a
failed attempt to escape him that caused
problems for
abasarala and since a lot of belters got
killed in the process that were on board
that made problems for fred johnson's
part of the opa
in that belters thought that the inners
were killing their people
we see the fallout of that when fred
johnson comes to medina
drummer resigns over it and then
eventually ashford will make the
decision that he's gonna go after marco
and kill him himself
this essentially is the beginning of the
end of albasarullah's
election she tries to salvage her
campaign and leaks images of the
environmental disasters
on illus but she finally does lose to
her opponent nancy gal
she also strains her marriage and pisses
off her husband
back on illus things finally start to
turn around
elvie figures out that holden's cancer
meds are the reason why he was the only
one who wasn't losing his vision
and she's able to make those meds and
give them to everyone where they get
their
sight back the water outside the ruins
starts to recede enough for them to
leave
as they're getting ready to do that
proto miller appears and we see this
glitching going on with the character
the real personality of miller fights
its way to the surface to talk to holden
and he explains that this one that's
wearing the hat the one that had been
talking to holden is the investigator
that it was basically using his corpse
and is what led them to travel through
the rings
knowing that they were going to turn the
planet on with this active protomolecule
when they got there
as i mentioned earlier that is the
directive of the protomolecule
and he says that the planet's already a
corpse and it ties into that second part
of what holden was saying at the end of
season three
about his saying that the civilization
that created the proto-molecule has been
destroyed
now we see that this planet was
destroyed and that by turning it back on
proto miller says he found a place where
the proto-molecule can't go
a dead spot that kills every bit of
proto-molecule that it touches
so they go to find out where that is and
see if they can
save everybody from what's happening
with the planet mercury is continuing to
make things complicated he's trying to
take out the rosie and their crew the
barbara piccola is in trouble because
the fusion drives don't work and it's
going to eventually fall
out of orbit so we have this thing going
on in orbit where the rosie's trying to
save the belters that are stuck in the
barbara piccola
mercury and shonda go after holden
they're followed by amos and elvi
they all come together and neither side
backs down
amos has to kill chandra and then
mercury shoots and wounds him
holden and miller find the thing that
they're looking for it's a remnant they
call it the bullet
it looks mysterious and no one really
knows what's going on with it
elvie finds holden and tells him that
amos has been shot so he
leaves the plan is that miller's gonna
figure out a way to integrate himself
with something
so that he can physically go through the
bullet outside holden runs into mercury
he shoots them just to disarm him he
doesn't want to kill him
and that leaves elvie inside the room to
help miller make it to the bullet
she falls through it and she has an
experience it's not clear exactly what's
going on
but miller's self-sacrifice does work
the network shuts down the planet turns
off
the fusion drives come back on and
basically the day is saved
out in the belt ashford's still hunting
marco in the process he interviews a
martian naval officer
and learns that there is a larger
conspiracy going on
unfortunately when ashford finds marco
his son phillip gets to drop on him
and that sets him up to be captured and
eventually spaced
he's able to record their conversation
secretly
and he does send that out before he dies
and we also
find out what marco's big plan is as he
launches
asteroids that are covered in stealth
tech towards the earth
he says they'll never see it coming and
we see on the displays
at least eight of these things are going
directly towards earth
one after the other so that is the big
setup for what the inners will be facing
when the new season starts
as far as tying things up outside the
ring gates the crew and their new
prisoner murtry
are back on the rossanante mercury and
lucia are supposed to be put on trial
but the crew lets her go the original
belters and the science team stay behind
on ellis
they plan to rebuild things and continue
to
learn more about this planet and with
that the ross and nantes leave
on mars bobby had stepped back from
helping aside but she realizes that this
last job they had that freaked her out
was actually a trap
she tries to stop it but she's not able
to
he's killed most of the other people
from the gang are killed
and we see that the belters that were
behind it are able to get off planet
when you look closely you can see that
this is naomi and marco's son
phillip so this is when they got that
stealth tech that they're able to use to
hide the asteroids that are hurtling
towards earth
as mentioned gal wins the election that
means the ring gates are going to be
opened and that the gold rush will be on
avasarala is really at a low point when
bobby reaches out to tell her that
there's martians trafficking military
weapons with the belters
and they decide to work together it's a
little more subtle here than it is in
the book but you also figure out that
avasarala was sending holden not because
she hoped that he would be successful
but that she thought that it would be
such a mess that it would work as a
deterrent to stop people from traveling
through the ring gates
and so that is where things end holden
and the crew destroyed the last bit of
proto-molecule that was on the rocinante
so we shouldn't see any more miller
there is still an
active proto-molecule sample the one
that they gave to fred johnson
way back when that's presumably still at
tycho
station we know more about naomi's
backstory now
and that she called in her favor from
fred johnson from way back in season one
she'll be going looking for her son now
that marco is raising his profile as
pushing back against the inners
and their plans of expansion we see that
he's quite charismatic and might turn
out to be a persuasive force of
resistance against the un
we don't know what he has going on with
mars but we do see him use philip as
part of the free navy
which is something that naomi is going
to be disappointed to find out
we'll mostly be leaving illis behind it
basically works as a bridge
to show all the problems that these
colonists may
run into whenever they go through the
rings but without giving anything away
some of these characters that were there
play an important role in later books
based on how the show repurposes some of
the roles we might even get to see more
of them going forward
rip to ashford and to miller they're
both going to be missed their fan
favorite characters their presence will
be missing in the future seasons
it'll be interesting to see how holden
adapts now that his long connection with
miller has finally come to an
end it's not clear where drummer will
land and what she'll be doing
with mars on the way out of power it
will be nice to see bobby and avasarala
working together again
for more discussion on what to expect in
season 5 check out the trailer breakdown
i made a few weeks ago
so i guess i will leave it there it's a
long video already and i have gone over
mostly everything that happened
i do have an ending explained video that
i made right after the season came out
last year
if you want more talk about the politics
and what's happening that goes into a
lot more of that
i will be covering season 5 with regular
weekly videos so
make sure you subscribe to my channel
please like this video if you enjoyed it
let me know what you think about season
4 and what you're excited about for
season five in the comments
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon